[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
week 17 happy nfl sunday everybody and
happy new year to you you just tapped
into the br betting squad ride presented
by draftkings live in the bleacher
report app i'm connor rogers alongside
the man what's going on greg how are you
feeling in the new year
feeling good connor feeling really good
actually feeling so good i'm in the
comments right now i am in the comments
i see my guy uh w tremble in the
comments man what's happening w tremble
you are walking away with the hoodie uh
shout out to everybody in the comments
it's mad love happy new year's everybody
connor
let's get this thing going man let's get
this get it going if you don't know the
deal by now you're running out of time
we are in week 17 and we are looking for
locks we are looking for touchdown
scorers we ask you every week in the app
we ask you on social who's getting in
the end zone and let's take a look at
the top choices that we receive cooper
cup and devonte adams they've been a
beast on the field they've been a beast
in fantasy and they have probably made
you a lot of money if you have bet on
them each and every week with their
props jt one of the only
non-quarterbacks that's been in the mvp
race this year he's got the raiders on
deck travis kelsey has gotten it done
down the stretch and a lot of big plus
money will any of them make an
appearance in the squad rod tournament i
think that's what everyone's wondering
right now greg
let him know what you got in store to
give away today
everybody here listen up
i'm not only giving away hoodies today
but i'm also giving away two not one but
two nfl jerseys one to the lucky lock
legend winner of the lock legend
tournament
and one to a lucky commenter like
yourself so don't go anywhere stick
around get some winners
and then you'll possibly win a jersey
but most importantly i need gifts i need
emojis
but connor
on this show
we want winners only please
and that's what i need in the comments
so you guys fill them up
that's right we need winners and we're
gonna find one today because we got the
squad ride tournament you know the deal
by now the last man standing last woman
standing last pet farm animal whatever
it may be they take home the nfl jersey
gift card and they take home the title
and then the man next to me is gonna
boost those odds so let's not waste any
time and get right into it with a
familiar face in w trammell let's see
what the lock of the week is w tremol
what's up vr nation we're back with lucy
let's see if she'll find us a cheesy
lock in the snow
aj dillon lock it in
new year but same rules apply do not
fade lucy lucy going with some big plus
money here plus 220 for aj dillon
we got to take on a challenger
right here we got arrington
bedding looking to knock off lucy let's
see the pick
hey bleach report betting i know it's
been a long 2021 there's been ups downs
wins and losses but there's one thing we
all want to start 2022 with a good bet
and that's why my pick for this sunday
is kendrick warren anytime touchdown
scored in the j worthers patriots game
the man with the patriots hat going with
the patriot getting in the end zone they
got the juiciest matchup against
jacksonville all right greg we got lucy
here going with the cheese with aj dylan
we got our helmet legend friend going
with kendrick form plus 180 plus 220.
this is one of the biggest plus money
rounds we've had in a while greg let him
know what we need to decide it
what i need you guys to do is get in the
comments and let me know for rocking
with aj dylan
we're rocking with my guy kb kendrick
bourne
uh i'll just jump right in here connor
aj dylan has three touchdowns on the
season i honestly thought these would be
bigger odds for him aaron jones is
playing today uh let's talk about aj i
mean uh aj dillard
nine attempts last week seven attempts
the week before that
this one seems a little risky to me
conor uh
even though i know he's taking on the
vikings defense they gave up over 100
yards rushing all of december
and we know that the packers like to run
the ball they like to establish the run
to get aaron rodgers going this one just
seems a little risky to me connor but
let's talk about kb let's talk about my
guy kendrick bourne he has five
touchdowns on the season but he hasn't
scored since november 28th conor you
know what that means people at home do
not be alarmed it only means that he is
due and they're taking on a jacksonville
jaguars team connor this is going to be
a stat game for every offensive player
on the patriots roster they're going to
look at this game as a stat game and
path those stats so give me kb i'm going
to lean kb conor which way are you
leading
i like where you're going greg right
when you look at aj dilling i think he's
only punched it in or scored in general
i think about four weeks this year
that's not a great sample size for a
really good player it's just it's work
share right it's the total that you're
getting it's the amount of work you're
getting targets carries and the bottom
line is on his best days he's splitting
those unless there's an injury and
that's not the case like you said greg
so
i'm with your point all the way i'm
going to take the match up here i'm
going to go with kendrick warren as much
as
new england might just run down their
throats all day they probably can but at
the end of the day it's still such a
good match up you've nailed it that he's
due these are big plus money for a
reason though i can see both sides of
the argument yeah and i think it's time
that you dive into those comments and
see if that's the case
connor let me get in the comments and
see what they are talking about i got
alex from northeast la that is his
username connor i'm not making this up
north east l.a says kendrick born and he
has a belichick
gif with a wink shout out to you north
east la you are walking away with a
hoodie i also got abby s 156
they got a kendrick bourne gift they got
a kendrick born gift shout out to you
you're walking away with the hoodie uh
at the bottom here i got i want to win
aj dillon to steal jones td at the goal
line okay i want to win you were also
walking already connor i'll just call it
there i'll just call it there
hold on i got one more isaac boatman aj
all day it appears connor the people
have spoken aj dylan
aj dylan
aj dylan is moving on to the next round
yay
dylan they are going with the rule of
gold
lucy the cheese legend moves on takes
down kendrick foreign despite our advice
and i appreciate when the comments go
the other way all right round two yeah
it's got a lot left here that was a
tight round one round two here
aaron wales
coming in to take down lucy let's see
what you got this week aaron
all right here we go new year new year
anytime touchdown score diggs vs atlanta
hey let's go all right let's run it
the dice legend the dice saying go for
it with the pc greg smile he's loving
this pick already he's loving the
staphon dig such down minus one and we
can flip those odds upside down get it
plus money
this is a a really tough matchup i think
diggs is coming in
hot
greg
how do you feel about this one i think i
know where you're gonna go but how are
you feeling here
uh before i get into how i'm feeling
connor because i'm feeling really good
but before i get into that i want
everybody everybody in the comments you
guys got to let us know if we're riding
with aj dylan or for riding with stefan
dix
connor
we talk about stefan diggs it seems like
every week and i love
every time we talk about this wide
receiver uh we all know that he's josh
allen's favorite target out there in
buffalo we know that but josh allen he
feeds stefan diggs regularly so with
that being said
my guy scored conor he scored in his
last two games so he's on a touchdown
streak they're they're they're getting
that connection ready for the playoffs
they're taking on an atlanta falcons
defense that scored uh actually that
scares nobody it does they don't scare
me connor uh and they're ranked 23rd in
passing yards so
i like this one i like the lean stephon
diggs here uh which way are you leaning
though
yeah i gotta go with the safe play as
well and i love what aj tyrell has done
for the falcons he's been tremendous but
you said it greg those overall stats
speak for themselves that this defense
as a unit just does not have enough even
with how good terrell's been and i don't
think he's gonna trail digs the entire
game and even if he does brian dabo with
the bills
they've been able to scheme him open he
can get open on his own he's one of the
best route runners in the nfl and we
watch what josh allen did to new england
last week it doesn't matter what defense
is out there and obviously atlanta's not
a great one it just doesn't matter what
defense is out there when josh allen is
on and he is right now he can make plays
with his legs he can make any throw in
the book with his arm so i love diggs
here i love dick skier i'm with you on
the last point there from the last
segment that i just worry about aj
dylan's total carries in this one
honestly as much as i love the cold
weather and that he can punch it in no
one wants to tackle him i love stephon
diggs this week
yeah uh i like stefan diggs let me see
what the comments are sent up i'm seeing
a lot of stephon diggs uh
gifts you don't gotta wait that time you
know where this one's gonna go
connor all right i don't wanna waste
time but i gotta give people i gotta
give people hoodies you know that's why
they come connor so here we go ela eli a
vesp
oh god eli v-e-z-o-v
producers yes that's what it is uh shout
out to you you're walking away what did
he put he put steph on dicks i also got
uh
i got drew a ro azarova a zarova drew
azarova lock it in digs all the way one
more connor then we're getting out of
here in chapman and chapman 23 he said
stefan diggs shout out to everybody that
i mentioned you all are walking away
with hoodies connor like you said we
really did not need to go to the
comments because we all know who's won
this matchup
but uh i'll officially say it stefan
diggs is moving on to the next round
you did the right thing got to give the
people their love but
stefan diggs in a runaway i'm sorry lucy
all right round three
final round
it's pretty tough to knock off stefan
diggs in my opinion and we might have to
look to
a lock legend a long time squad ride
legend to at least give it a fight we're
dialing it up riley serbo speaking of
those farms oh a hall of fame
what do you got
all right we've got cooper cup and
damien harris
we're gonna see which one's the chicken
oh
oh it's looking like a cooper cup
of cupcake
cooper cup
cooper cup
he's got one of the best match-ups of
the week right here he's been
the best ppr fantasy player the best
the best pvr fantasy player and you know
what that means he's getting in the end
zone but staphon digs still liking it
all right greg this is as good as a
final match up as we can ask for
you know what to do tell them what we
need
people in the comments everybody that's
watching what i need you to do is get in
the comments and let us know if we
should rock with cooper cup if we should
rock with stefan diggs or if we should
simply rock with both because that is
the way i'm leaning connor i like both
of these picks and i'm actually torn on
which one i want to win
uh this tournament but
let's talk about cooper cup he did not
score last week conor he went for 10 and
109. he went on 109 yards off of 10
receptions but he did not score that
broke a streak
that he he scored four he scored in four
uh three previous weeks before that he
scored in three previous weeks before
that that would have been the fourth
week that broke the street guess what do
not be alarmed everybody i think the
streak is gonna start again this week
and simply because i'll leave it on this
they're facing this ravens team who's
banged up they're banged up they have
practice squad players out there playing
defense
i like my chances with cooper cup to
score a touchdown he's been doing it all
year give me cooper cup to score i also
like stefan diggs so i really don't know
which way conor i really don't know
which way but which way are you leaning
you cannot go wrong here right we're
joking that you can parlay them both
greg can you boost parlays ask trap
kings next time can you boost the
parlays i love diggs i love cup but
i mean you're speaking gospel you nailed
it the cooper cup has the best matchup
because the ravens it's not their fault
this isn't their real defense this isn't
their real corners they're just down and
out number one two three the list goes
on and on the amount of injuries they've
dealt with but specifically in that
secondary in a defense that's drawn up
by wink martindale that they gotta send
guys to get home with pressure and it
puts a lot of pressure on the corners on
the back end to hold up in coverage they
don't have their top guys to do that and
certain teams against young quarterbacks
you can succeed doing that against matt
stafford cooper cup obj
it's just it's a tough task it's not
going to be easy so i love cooper cup i
really really like stefan diggs i love
cooper cup this week
let them take us home let them take us
home i'm not going to be mad with either
selection here
i like i like what you did there connor
you said let them take us home so let me
get in here and see what they are
talking about i got m kent 93 he has a
stefan diggs gif and he's laughing shout
out to you mkint93 you are walking away
with a hoodie uh isaac boatman is back
in the comments asking if we can't have
both yeah why don't we have both
parliament in fact uh brian
the real buddha 53 says only one choice
winners only please and he has
a gift of jared goff
is that jericho or is that cooper cup
bro
i don't know if that's jared goff that
that that's controversy there that looks
like jared goff but but but he's he's
apparent as cooper cup so uh or he's
saying that it's cooper cup so shout out
to you real buddha i'll give you a
hoodie for that uh okay connor i'm gonna
make a decision next one i see i'm just
gonna make a decision
scroll all right
phx1 says you already know and this
looks like cooper cup in fact this one
actually looks like cooper cup this is a
gif of cooper cup giving us the shrugs
emoji uh
i'm gonna make the decision right there
connor i'm gonna make the decision right
there
it appears we are all riding with cooper
cup to score a touchdown today
let me show you guys some magic let's
pull up the graphic please
and
there it is up top poof there's the
magic thanks to our friends at
draftkings we're gonna boost that from
minus 165 to plus 110 yes this is plus
money for a cooper cup touchdown check
out br betting socials for a link to the
odds boost send us your screenshots of
your bets send us your videos
and your celebrations but most
importantly we will winners only please
connor
let's get it done man let's get it done
cooper cup gonna be a winner stefan
diggs think it's gonna be a winner love
what you did with those odds there greg
make sure everybody gets the draftkings
and
it's good idea to trail that one
speaking of winners only we are not done
community comment contest time you know
the deal by now we're asking you
something different every week on social
we're asking you in the vr betting
stream in that bleacher report app this
week we want to know who are you betting
on to be one of the final playoff teams
who's either on the outside just looking
in and is going to punch through or
who's going to hold down that spot who's
going to get it done in these last two
weeks so greg
what do we get this week who are people
riding with who are they have their
belief in in week 17 and then 18.
what i need everybody to do what i need
everybody to do is you guys let me know
which comment you guys like better that
person will be walking away with a
hoodie connor are you ready because i
think we need to jump right into it
let's just jump right into it my guy
kelly lacy
says
the chargers will be in the playoffs
wow connor he says the chargers will be
in the playoffs i
they just been so inconsistent for me i
don't know if i can agree with this why
are we even talking about this connor
why are this is what we accept why are
we talking about
the chargers
in the they should have been
they should have been stamped their uh
stamped their way into the playoffs
connor how do you feel about this
listen kelly i'm sorry i and i love the
confidence in your squad right here just
saying they're going to be in the
playoffs but
greg i'm i'm with you what if they
haven't given us a reason to trust them
yet right we love justin herrera we love
the weapons they have yeah they've dealt
with the coveted list as much as anybody
injuries always
staley's been up and down as a rookie
head coach he's been one of the better
rookie head coaches but it's been up and
down
but
they controlled their destiny
essentially and they got walloped by the
texans last week the texans greg it's
not a technical those are the games you
gotta win especially in crunch time so
the i think the charger schedule on the
way out starting with the broncos today
is favorable it's favorable for them to
get to 10 wins finish 10-7 make the
playoffs and then you can make some
noise with your young quarterback but i
have one rule in betting and in football
in general if you haven't given me a
reason ever to trust you why should i
start right now and i'm sorry the
chargers fall under that bucket
yeah i i agree with you i i agree with
you i don't know about this one kelly
but let's see what the next one holds
conor we got jodie the kid jody the kid
says if baltimore gets
this upset on sunday they can definitely
squeeze
in i agree here i absolutely agree here
if they if they can somehow connor they
can somehow get a win today against the
rams
they can squeeze in the playoffs this
one's actually correct in my opinion
which way do you feel how do you feel
connor which way it's a good caveat yeah
if they can pull off the up what matters
is today pull off the upset against the
rams and you know our lack of faith in
their secondary kind of indicates we
think they probably won't be able to do
it unless lamar can do something really
really special unless that offense you
know and we haven't seen lamar healthy
in a while now let's not forget that so
he's right jody the kid you're spot on
you win today i think you go home and
beat the steelers in baltimore i think
the energy would be great i think they'd
be getting a little healthier at that
time and i think with all of the chips
on the table they would get it done but
it's just tough it's a tough matchup for
them today they got to get through step
one but this comment is not wrong i want
to make that clear
comment is not wrong let me get into the
comments because i want to see if they
think that if my guide jody is wrong or
if he's right uh
i'm in the comments locks underwater
says this is a great show god is popcorn
shout out to you locks underwater for
the good vibes you were walking away
with a hoodie uh
i got
okay they're all over the place in the
comments the chiefs the chill they ain't
beating the rams uh almond zota says
chill they not beating the rams uh ben
man 56 says lamar shouldn't play today
connor they're all over the place in the
comments as you guys can see look i got
uh mango singles
ak blues talking about the bengals
uh we got adams and with the win today
philly is going all the way look they're
all over the place so guess what i'm
gonna make a decision here i am going to
make a decision and conor i like what
jody said i mean because it's it's true
like if baltimore somehow someway
gets the upset today against the rams i
mean
they can definitely squeeze in and
that's a true statement so i'm gonna
rock with my guy jody jodie you are
walking away with the hoodie connor uh
i think it's time for
the commenter's favorite part of the
show i think it's time for their
favorite part yeah sure
i think we're getting there we got to
knock out some props first so it's time
for prop lock or drop it you guys let us
know if you like the prop you're going
to lock the prop or you want to roll it
up throw it in the trash drop the prop
so greg what are we starting with this
week for our prop segment
what i need you guys to do
is get in the comments and tell me if
you think each prop is a lot or if we
should drop it i'm giving hoodies to my
favorite confident uh to my favorite
commenter let's start with jonathan
taylor
to rush for over or under 107 and a half
rushing yards today connor he leads the
nfl
in rushing yards with
1626 yards the raiders have not given up
more than 89 yards on the ground in the
past two games the coast can also clinch
a playoff berth with the win today i'm
honestly throwing off about the second
statistic that i just said the raiders
uh have not given up more than 89 yards
on the ground but uh is that changing
today conor is that changing today
as stephen a smith once famously said
greg we don't care we do not care what
the raiders have done in the last couple
weeks it does not matter jonathan you
want to talk about what the raiders have
done the last couple weeks jonathan
taylor has gone over this number the
last three weeks so yeah this might be
iron meeting iron right now but i'm
gonna roll with jt and carson wentz it
sounds like he's gonna be cleared in
time to play we also don't care about
that either he's not asked to do a lot
this is the colts have the playoffs in
sight right there's that light at the
end of the tunnel what do you do when
you get there you do what you know best
you do what you do best and that is turn
around hand the ball to jonathan taylor
over and over and over again so jonathan
taylor smashed over
107.5 yards
yeah i'm right there behind you connor
we're talking about the oakland raiders
defense i'm honestly surprised that they
haven't gave up more than 89 yards and
that's no like i'm honestly surprised at
the raiders defense uh have been
stifling the run but yeah that's
changing this week jonathan taylor he's
in mvp discussions for a reason guys
he's in mvp discussions for a reason uh
i think he has a big game today connor
he has a big game today in the coach
they stamp their way into the playoffs
with a win against the raiders today so
i'm locking that one uh let's move on oh
actually connor actually the producer
just whispered in my ear give away some
hoodies so i'm in the comments i am in
the comments
and uh aaron sham 45 says jay train is
rolling today shout out to
says over over and over again uh
he's rocking he's rocking with the over
and you connor uh okay i got
i got oh you guys just saw it right now
i love this the jt over
yeah the yeah the comments are loving it
uh okay i got one more one more adam
adam harar says i don't know man i love
taylor but nelson's out but that yeah i
mean yeah it's still but it's the
raiders
shout out to everybody that commented
though shout out to everybody that
commented you guys are walking away with
hoodies uh everybody that i mentioned
that comment you guys are walking away
with these let's go to the second one
connor let's go to the second aaron
rodgers to throw over or under
265 yards today
he has thrown 34 touchdown passes since
his last interception against an nfc
north team he's been killing the nfc
north rogers has thrown for 16
touchdowns and zero interceptions over
the past five games connor talk to me
it's gonna be cold there it's gonna be
cold
do you think this is a locker should we
drop it
greg it's a trap bet it's a drop and
it's gonna be close but this is the trap
because everybody looks at it and goes
aaron rodgers on cruise control right
now we know minnesota is in rough shape
especially in the secondary that group
has not been good this year which is
usually
one of mike zimmer's strong strengths
this is a trap though because they don't
need him to go over this mark to win
this game they don't need him to go over
this mark to blow out the vikings the
vikings do not have kirk cousins this
should not be a shootout it's freezing
cold they're gonna both teams are gonna
lean on their running backs you're going
to see plenty of cook you're going to
see a little bit of madison you're going
to see plenty of jones and aj dillon i
worry greg that this is a game the
packers come out the defense capitalizes
on some turnovers with short fields they
don't need aaron rodgers dropping back
40 times he can go for 230 yards and
three touchdowns today and the packers
can run the ball out run the clock out
in the second half and win this one
easily total trap prop hit the under
tell me i'm wrong comment connor
no no no thomas don't tell him that he's
wrong because i'm actually with you
connor i'm actually with last time last
time the number was similar to this
number we saw it and we were hammering
the errand right
and we were wrong
this time we saw the number we're
observing it and you're going under and
i'm gonna go under simply because i
mentioned earlier in the show
that vikings run defense uh
i think the packers are gonna take a
place from what the 49ers did against
the vikings and they're also going to
take a pace from what the rams did to
the vikings last week they ran the
football and uh so with that being said
i don't see aaron rodgers throwing for
over
262 and a half yards if they're going to
be running the football and it's going
to be cold connor so
the the the dots are just not connecting
for me so i think i'm going to drop it
as well i'm in the comments now i'm
going to see what there's what they're
saying in the comments connor
um
dorian dboy22 says you are wrong thank
you dorian appreciate that hopefully
you're right but you are walking away
with a hoodie uh
i got
i got ann sharma under easy trap for
sure he's rocking with you connor shout
out to you and sharma you were walking
away with idiot i got one more
one more uh oh hold on i seen it i want
to go back to it i want to go back there
it is dave strout 09
rogers would at least get 300 fade greg
please yes there it is the first one
today fade greg yes you guys please
please please fade me please pay me
listen to my guy uh but yeah shout out
to you brother i'm gonna send you good
vibes you send me bad boys i'm going to
send you good vibes though you're
walking away with a hoodie connor we're
dropping this one
we're dropping yeah
we're dropping it all the way and we are
not dropping our boldest bets before we
get out of here it's what we do we don't
care win lose we have fun with them
throw the hail mary's let's get into it
greg let him know what we need before we
get out of here and i know you still got
more stuff to give away
what we need you guys to do
is to get in the comments and let us
know if you're rocking with connor or if
you're rocking with me uh if you're
rocking with both just get in the
comments let us know connor
let's get right to it brother
greg i cooked this one up just for you
man we're starting with your boy trey
lance right here to get in the end zone
with a touchdown parlay not just trey
lance who listen kyle shanahan is going
to help his young quarterback and do
what he does best right now that's get
him moving get him running make things
happen with his legs in the red zone
while he continues to grow as a passer
on the other side of this jacksonville
almost gave up 300 rushing yards to the
new york jets last week what do you
think new england's gonna do to them and
you nailed it earlier in the show greg
stat game stat game stat game the
patriots are angry pissed and want to
put that bill's loss behind them well
guess what you got served up the five
course easy meal that is the
jacksonville jaguars damien harris he's
getting in the end zone the parlay lock
here what do you got for us
i actually love this what i need
everybody to do is stop stop what you're
doing take a screenshot
take a picture of connor's bet or or go
put it in right now uh because i
actually love this trey lance we know
what the niners do in the red zone when
he's in the game and damian harris uh
like i said stat game for everybody on
that new england's offense connor i
really like that bro uh but there's a
game
nfc east matchup actually
going on we got the philadelphia
eagles taking on the washington football
team connor
i got two star receivers on each team
i'm gonna go with a combined yards over
prop there it is on the screen right
there devonta adams terry mclaren to go
over 149 and a half receiving yards
these they've been struggling i'm not
gonna lie
they've both been kind of struggling but
that changes today big game
big time matchup and uh you know big
time players usually show up for those
big time matchups so i see these two
players balling out and getting over
149 and a half receiving yards for
today's game
division game let me hop in the comments
gotta get in on the division vision game
smith coming off 80 yards in their last
week's division game right against the
giants so maybe devonta smith can get
hot now he can build off that 80 yard
game we already know what scary terry
can do he's one of the better young
receivers in the nfl he's not had a lot
of quarterback help throughout his
career but when he's on he's unstoppable
so i like that that's not a crazy number
i mean if you get one of those guys to
100 yards it's gonna exactly so i'm
riding with you right where's that
exactly bro
exactly anybody either one gets to 100
has a good chance of hitting i like that
ah okay here we go uh richie the coach
says now washington quarterback is too
inconsistent shout out to you richie uh
you're walking away with hoodie i like
that i'll fire that actually in fact um
here we go let's move on scary terry has
been the fade lately uh d-boy yeah but
that we're we're we're we're we're
no those are bad vibes those are bad
vibes
both for sure shots oh we don't want to
block them let's fire that shout out to
you cleo uh i got one more in me
here we go
wada watages wada just says both you
guys rock good vibes in 2022 shout out
to everybody that i just mentioned you
guys are walking away with hoodies oh
connor i gotta give away a jersey i
gotta give away a jersey brother i'm not
done
okay hold on hold on hold on i just saw
another one i just saw another one
i gotta find it i gotta find it i gotta
find it it was a fab i gotta find it
i gotta find it all right here we go i'm
going i'm going with the over analyzer
connor ivory i don't even know what that
means but i like because they combined
us too whatever bro it's good vibe see
more you'll walk away with a jersey
you throw you throw shade at me i throw
light at you brother but you're watching
greg
the bigger person is what we like to
call it which i respect shout out to
everybody that joined the show today
shout out to all the locked legends we
had aaron g whales we had w trammell uh
riley serbo was in there
we had i mean we had locks galore there
and i cannot forget arrington betting
was the last one in there i thanks all
the commenters if you want a hoodie you
want a jersey whatever it is greg
shouted you out don't worry br bending
is gonna dm you within the next 24 hours
and we will be back doing this next week
we will be doing this throughout the
playoffs we're not just doing this like
the regular season like fantasy football
this is the real deal don't forget
cooper cup maybe staphon digs a little
bit as well but cooper cup boosted in
the draftkings app thanks to greg's
magic i'm connor rogers alongside the
man greg ivory we will catch you here
same time same place next week
[Music]
so